também pouco safadão hoje e aí agora
quero meu canal tudo com vocês eu estou
ótimo é certo que eu tô indo pra mercado
já temos já sei o que é que eu vou me
preparar
placar final de ano em família você já
sabe tudo o que vai acontecer em julho
você já tem que estar se preparando
psicologicamente pra o final de ano em
família perto da virada ceia de natal a
ser linda fato linda maravilhosa é tempo
de ser gente legal é tempo de ser gente
boa é ter pité logo as outras pessoas é
tempo você pecarem compaixão com os
animais de vocês e compaixão com o mundo
todo o peru que se [ __ ] não vamos chamar
todo mundo mas tacna machadada no
pescoço pelo que sem dó e chega os
parentes de longe é muito difícil minha
família toda é sempre uma tia de muito
muito muito muito longe você não fala há
muito muito muito muito tempo a ele liga
para sua mãe para desejar feliz ano novo
que a mãe faz ela quer forçar você a
falar com esse título lhe ia tudo bom é
obrigada muito obrigada tem vão mandar
vou mandar lembranças praia está aqui do
meu lado diz que quer falar contigo
mulher é que se quer falar até porque
quer morte vai falar assim tá aqui no
meu nariz que carro que quero falar não
tinha como é a que diz que tá dodói
funkeiro vai passar férias aqui
rapidinho
[Música]
a oi tinha no bosque os que vêm à festa
de final de ano mas nós pergunta que meu
tempo era um filho feliz ano novo e não
lembra da titia a tia pegou você no colo
quando tinha 6 meses de nascido lembro
dia né
levo lembro sim a memória do satanás
para lembrar assim ó tem aquele parente
que o time b passa de tony dizendo que
vai se comportar para quando esse ano
vai ser diferente quando há sete horas
da noite dilma viveu tudo ataca com um
torcedor que sempre acontece um novo que
estabelecer reúne a família é um na
família todos lota a casa de gente
sempre tem uma prima que inventa de
gravidade o menino nasce antes do natal
quando ele o ano novo no paço a virada
do ano todinho chora ano meu deus ele já
no um feliz ano novo
parabéns feliz ano novo com muita paz e
prosperidade aqui em um ano todo de
fazer isso aí não tem que inventar de 10
que priquito vem mais gente não brinca
em a dor que a partir de julho a 1º de
janeiro a 11 de março o time nasceu
novembro devem ficar tudo engano a
virada do ano a temporada me para me
botar muita bola na cama de solteiro não
é bacana de quem na cama do casal da
casa porque tem que botar menino no
lugar dele não vai cair
bota num centro da cama de casa acaba a
festa embora vai embora para quem está
um novo novo táxi novo todo mundo então
casada do boi chega na cama a 1 no meio
da campanha logo pequim e é nossa é viu
nem colocou ainda o menino já nasceu
atingir aqueles ir embora de gripe
parabéns
eu não dou feliz ano novo
aí vai cortar pirua rampinha gota no
cotovelo mas não presta
tudo bom muita facilidade eu mas você
vai cumprir que tem a mesma idade que
você sempre se não a gente bate os
pensamentos seus pensamentos são igual
vamos lá chegar vamos entrosar e aí
prefeito ano novo
obrigada pelo abraço ela tá com saudade
já na semana passada a última vez que
tive foi no ano passado devolve feliz
ano novo que eu te dei você não merece a
mesma se é ótimo você vê todas as
pessoas que você tinha saudade de ver
todos os seus primos todos os seus
parentes falar com a sua tia de longe o
bebê da sua prima falar com sua prima
típico de final de ano nunca muda eu
sempre mostra a você aqui as coisas acho
engraçado o cotidiano e eu quero que
você comece aqui embaixo que você mais
gosta na virada do ano começa aqui
embaixo você tiver no facebook marcão
amigos seus comentários para poder ver e
curte aposta está no youtube da lac no
vídeo vão bater o recorde do lago dessa
vez está quanto mais light mas vídeo se
inscreve no campeonato perdeu de novo e
é claro míssil no instagram destaque na
descrição do vídeo você vai fazer legais
por noé ter muita falta em balé nós e
[Música]